[Music]
so as Joe Biden's document disaster goes
from bad to worse vice president Harris
she doesn't seem to want anything to do
with this now here she is ignoring
questions about this earlier today take
a listen
[Music]
um
all right here with reaction to our
giggling vice president and Biden's big
classified documents Scandal I call him
the great one he is the host of the
number one show on weekends life liberty
Levin nationally syndicated radio host
the great one Mark Levin thank me God
bless us
um well I don't know if you want to talk
about Kamala you don't have to our
giggling vice president but I know you
have a lot to say on the documents
yeah a couple of things here Sean in all
seriousness
the only person who knows how the
documents were removed from the skiff in
the Senate which I understand
from Democrats like durbins almost an
impossibility would be Joe Biden
so in other words he secreted the
documents on his body somewhere maybe he
pulled a Sandy Burger maybe just put him
in his jacket who knows
so he's been doing this a long time uh
the University of Delaware documents
they need to do a review of those
because that's where his Center records
are
something here there needs to be a
Federal grand jury investigating by not
Pence
we know what happened with Pence it's
pretty obvious what happened with Pence
but the various locations
I mean they have a grand jury for Trump
and we know where his documents are they
know where the documents are they were
negotiating over the documents for some
reason they decided to criminalize the
entire event while he wouldn't give them
the documents back are you kidding me
just a matter of time you negotiate
these things and you don't run around
yelling obstruction obstruction there's
no obstruction
you know you have these phony legal
analysts and these these pathetic
professors running around there is no
obstruction
the FBI could have taken them any time
they wanted they know where they were
and they were protected by the Secret
Service uh in the case of buying he's
got documents from the Senate he's got
documents in a closet in a phony Think
Tank uh where money's being laundered
for him from the Communist Chinese he's
got documents next to this Corvette he's
got documents in his fake library at
home he's got that God knows where he's
got more documents
so but only Joe Biden can tell us how
some of these documents wound up where
they did so he needs to be questioned
under oath now there's other things
going on here that are very troubling to
me
the reason why Merrick Garland will not
appoint a special counsel to investigate
the Biden crime family is because Biden
and that whole team of left-wing
reprobates over there at the Department
of Justice they know this they look
under the sheets
and all the bugs are going to come out
they know if they start with one email
it's going to lead to others they know
if they start with one wire transfer
if they they bring bobolinsky in front
of a grand jury it's going to lead to
trouble they know from other emails that
Joe Biden already lied to the American
people he knew businesses that his son
was involved in the hell did he think of
someone's hitching rides to see China on
Air Force two or where he got diamonds
and all the rest of it
Joe Biden is a cover-up artist and
that's exactly what's going on right
here you know the funny thing every time
they keep showing his Corvette in the
Box I keep looking at that house
how the hell do you get a mansion like
that on a senator's salary then he's got
a mansion at Rehoboth Beach right near
the ocean he's got a classic Corvette
how does a guy on a senator's salary
earn all the I think Senators earn like
180 185 000 he used to brag that he was
the poorest man in the Senate actually
was the dumbest man in the Senate I
don't know about the poorest man now
some of these ex-presidents and vice
presidents let me show you how pathetic
the media are
so I'm reading here in the Daily Mail
and there's others that say the four
former presidents have no classified
documents really and how do we know that
because statements were put out
and in the case of obami says look even
the archive said when I left they
secured my documents and so forth hey
Barack
you claim to be a very smart man you
know those documents Biden has when he
was vice president through your
documents
it was the Obama Administration so
obviously the archives doesn't have all
your classified documents because Biden
took some and so we don't have
confidence in that George Bush says out
there you know when he left they took
all his documents and and same with his
dad and and of course uh the vice
president's Quail Cheney Gore say the
same thing here's the question that
should be asked
remember Joe Biden said in September he
he didn't take classified documents and
he dumps on Trump remember Pence was a
very honorable man he says in November I
didn't take classified documents but
they had classified documents so these
ex-presidents and ex-vice presidents
have done and said the same thing uh
well we didn't take documents so when's
the last time you looked for documents
in your many homes and in your
businesses in your offices in your
presidential libraries
Mike Pence went back he didn't think he
took documents then they looked and they
found some when is the last when is the
first time even your private lawyers and
staff presumably with clearances look
through these facilities to see if if in
fact Cheney and Gore and the others have
private dot they haven't
so this story means nothing and the
bottom line is if Joe Biden can walk out
there out of the skiff in the Senate
were prolonged documents how do we know
other Senators haven't done this and
well now I've been made mistakenly
interpreted as saying this is no big
deal everybody does it quite the
contrary
it is a big deal
but what bothers me is that Donald Trump
is treated one way and every one of the
others has treated another and so USA
Today puts out this ridiculous story and
says the vice president can declassify
documents so after everybody's saying
Trump can't
because there's no evidence that he did
they say vice president can no he can't
well we have a 2009 executive order
where where Obama said you know people
could declare no no it's called the
Constitution the reason the president
can classify and declassify at will
is because he's the head of the
executive branch that's the reason the
vice president is not he's no different
than the Secretary of State for these
purposes or the Attorney General so the
vice president cannot declassify
information at will
people who classify information Obama
said can declassify it fine they have
rules they have to follow the president
Trump does not and people say well
what's the evidence that he Declassified
I'll tell you the evidence the boxes
were taken when he was president
and removed and taken to Mar-A-Lago
gee what that means they're Declassified
no they're classified so you mean Donald
Trump intentionally
violated the law no it's ridiculous the
whole case against Trump is ridiculous
and the more this we see the more
Preposterous it is so I have a
suggestion Sean just get the longest
piece of crime tape you can and wrap it
around Washington D.C because most of
these guys have done exactly this that's
it I'm done could I ask one question
before you're done how could be the only
guest in the history of cable news that
tells the host when they're done I just
try to understand that it was a great
analysis because I'll tell you why
because most guests are looking for face
time I say what I have to say and I get
the hell off I said I'm I'm done that's
it I'm done I'm out of here thank me God
bless us all right that's why we call
him the great one Mark Levin life
liberty Levin right here Fox News every
Sunday night 8 P.M hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else